[Música]
hola que tal qual é a natureza humana
verdadeira coração batendo no peito
os pensamentos acontecendo uma presença
que é totalmente nata de falta de
fábrica desde a eternidade como um
bebezinho até agora
muito antes da formação da personalidade
muito antes de você pensar quem você é
um homem os apelos ao ice e um bingo um
macaco inteligente como gosta de chamar
qual é a natureza em comum de todos que
estão aqui e todos que estão no planeta
essa questão me puxava e quando eu
cheguei perto dos meus 30 anos posso
chamar assim de uma certa crise
existencial com cinco atividades
profissionais advogando construindo o
prédio coordenando um curso de
pós-graduação de 360 horas aulas com bar
e restaurante uma loja de chocolates o
que mostra que a gente coloca aquela
ideia de o nosso fazer tem que nos
trazer um certo prazer mas nada disso me
realizava eu senti uma inquietude por
baixo disso seguia que estava seguindo o
script social gera life que era droga
era big fucking televisivo você está
seguindo é algo que está dentro da
cultura como se a realização fosse uma
régua que a cultura coloca e não um
estado de espírito interno e daí essa
angústia com os dois anos de divã
bastante estudos de psicologia e
psicanálise e de repente houve uma
proposta inusitada ficar quatro dias
quatro noites sem comer nem beber nem
falar nada com ninguém sozinho consigo
mesmo junto à natureza
um desenho ancestral
ameríndio a busca de visão a visão quest
onde eles tinham no 'hall' para colocar
o ser humano em contato com a sua
natureza mais profunda
todos os medos vieram assim na sensação
já do corpo e na ansiedade que é meio
que colocava em homs maluco ficando
quatro dias quatro noites sem comer nem
lê nada junto à natureza só consigo
mesmo e não morre um troço desses em
dizer que morre morre para aquele que
você pensa que é porque você já notou
que você não é aquilo que você pensa que
é
se pra questão muito simples você não é
um pensamento você é vida em totalidade
e eu abracei peguei eu vou nessa nessa
coisa nada tamanha realizando cinco
atividades profissionais correndo por um
lado pro outro e eu não tenho a menor
idéia do que eu quero realmente pra mim
quem sabe essa passa essa proposta
inusitada de busca divisão possa dar uma
esclarecida né
um divã existência um pouco radical onde
todos os medos vão ser confrontados e
todas as inquietudes e também as
memórias e quem sabe os próprios anseios
do coração subir a tal da montanha e não
era nada do que eu estava pensando
foram quatro dias de desespero
eu não conseguia ficar em silêncio
comigo mesmo era quase um survival
eu comecei a perceber que a cabeça não
para ela fica pensando
comecei a notar que eu carregava uma
ansiedade latente pequeno stress uma
pequena angústia que já estava
depositada no corpo e que ia
simplesmente silenciosamente midani
nando toda a minha espontaneidade eo meu
tesão de viver saída que dessa
experiência desses quatro dias
completamente vazado não volto mais
nesse troço aqui fiz um investimento
para pagar pela gente passou um mês eu
comecei a me sentir bem mais leve
parecia que eu tinha deixado tijolos
naquela montanha
eu comecei a notar que tudo o que eu
fazia era para buscar de alguma forma o
desejo dos outros da sociedade da
família o pai a mãe absolutamente todas
as minhas escolhas seja do direito seja
associação inconsciente e vou buscar uma
coisa prazerosa bar restaurante lojas de
chocolate eram coisas que haviam sido
depositadas em mim e que passado já
incorporar e tomá las como minha eu
representava um papel de mim que não era
mais espontâneo como uma criança
e daí eu resolvi não vamos continuar
esse negócio
no segundo ano você sobe para a mesma
experiência pra ficar sete dias na
montanha no 3º ano sobe novamente para
ficar nove dias na montanha e finalmente
no quarto ano pra encerrar um ciclo de
busca divisão 13 dias consigo mesmo
junto à natureza escutando os
passarinhos cantar escutando a grama
crescer sempre os quatro dias primeiros
você percebia até uma turbulência porque
você chega a conter o ritmo social com o
teu ritmo cultural a cabeça lá a milhão
os próprios animais eu pude perceber que
um afastamento de você
pensando demasiadamente pensante e no
momento que você começa a se integrar a
integrar aquela natureza se entregar ao
momento o acatamento vai surgindo o
silêncio vai aparecendo e isso que a
própria natureza se aproxima de você
tive a oportunidade nos meus nove dias
de simplesmente assistir em contemplação
beija-flor voar e pousar no meu ombro
desde então nunca tive mais a questão de
carregar uma ansiedade dentro de mim por
um simples fato essa tecnologia
ameríndia me possibilitou vir a mim
mesmo
com todas as formas culturais mentes
apreendidos para investigação da minha
própria natureza de quem era de fato não
me silenciavam a ponto de eu escutar
isto eu estava vivendo a partir disto da
cabeça e fui buscar na antropologia
linguagem para dar conta dessa
experiência busca divisão temas cal
dança do sol cerimônia de medicina
fizeram parte da minha pesquisa de campo
e da minha vida investigação
antropológica participando do festival
ea não há tanto com os índios lá na
região acreana da amazônia pode também
sentir de perto uma outra perspectiva
existencial da natureza de quem somos
a minha jornada começou com uma busca de
autoconhecimento para conhecer o
henrique o conhecimento horizontal da
personalidade dos gostos para poder
decidir melhor fazer melhores escolhas
buscar coisas que ressoa sem um
pouquinho mais para os meus interesses
mas a pegadinha era que dentro dessa
experiência radical isso me foi roubado
e foi colocada uma proposta de quem eu
era verticalmente existencialmente
naturalmente muito antes de um
condicionamento e poder notar isso e
trazer através da linguagem antropologia
ao que já foi compartilhado nas falas
anteriores e que a gente tem que ter com
clareza nesses tempos o formatar mento o
condicionamento cultural do qual a gente
absorve desde a ter da difusão menta a
idéia de um erro você seria um eu
psicológico na cabeça o tempo todo
usando esse artifício para a sua
navegação enquanto a mensagem o legado a
herança desses antepassados que deixaram
condensado em experiências tais quais
com a busca da visão e o tema fiscal
eles estão a colocar que a natureza
humana é o coração verifica agora
mesmo se a tua existência persiste na
presença do presente momento na batida
do coração ou na persistência dos
pensamentos e de verdade em contemplação
eu pude perceber que não é você que
pensa a mente penso tanto que você
observa mente pensando assim como a
mente é algo que está projetado de fora
pra dentro pelos signos culturais a
personalidade reside nesse ambiente
então identificado com esse papel
estamos todos a sustentar a nossa
persona o personagem representando um
papel de si no mundo isso gasta uma
energia da está simbolizado nesses
tempos
hoje em dia as pessoas se preocupam mais
em aparentar estar bem estar bem de fato
estão preocupadas mais em aparência da
sua imagem do que aquilo que sentem de
verdade daquilo que está espontâneo
interno já em si
se você nota com a clareza do ser humano
que você é com a inteligência que é o
que estamos dizendo é muito claro e auto
evidente se você olha o homo sapiens que
está aqui acontece uma personalidade
novamente nele mas de verdade você não é
o conteúdo
você é o contingente a vida em
totalidade no momento presente e
descendo dessa montanha a realização de
concluir um circo de busca de visão e
carregar o tema fiscal que é uma outra
cerimônia ameríndia que tem mais de 10
mil anos que é conhecido também como
tenda do sol onde você entra em uma
tenda com o formato de uma barriga de um
ver onde vão te pedras aquecidas em um
fogo e essas pedras de um fogo masculino
vão entrar no interior dessa tenda como
quem fecunda para a possibilidade de um
renascimento e nessa experiência poder
sentir a natureza em comum dos seres
humanos porque nota
ana o ser social eu com a sua
condicionamento tem os seus espaços
o germânico tem o dele o japonês
o americano você não conversa com uma
pessoa muito próxima muito distante
dependendo do condicionamento
culturalmente apreendidos
mas qual é o espaço de ser humano está
totalmente terminado em parentada
abraçado sentindo completamente igual
completamente a mesma coisa que anima o
olho do lado de cá que olha para aí é a
mesma coisa que animam o olho de lá
olhando para o lado de cá
a natureza é mesmo confúcio já
professava 400 séculos 400 anos antes de
cristo
a natureza dos homens é a mesma o que os
distingue são os seus atos
vem um cidadão roy wagner que é um
mestre em antropologia reversa e ele vem
e diz o seguinte o homem é o chamando os
seus significados
você está o tempo todo construindo tem
um sentido de um mundo nessa experiência
da montanha eu percebi que a vida em si
é inalcançável de significação
mas nem por isso deixa a abertura que
você dê um significado sentido da
própria realização desde dentro e não
com a régua dos outros
afinal realização para um e para outro
pode variar
você usa isso com qual régua dos outros
o da voz do seu próprio coração
no fim essa tecnologia meníngea da busca
de visão eles têm algo como um plantio
de seres humanos eles plantam gente para
acolher gente um pouquinho mais humana e
melhorada no sentido de ouvir a verdade
daquilo que o próprio sente desde antes
de comprar a verdade do mundo fora de
você então poeticamente no estudo
antropológico que a gente aponta que
está implícito nisso é plantar o coração
na natureza para acolher a natureza do
coração
isso pra mim é expressão da realização
que é um
estado de espírito interno indizível não
mensurável
vou ser sincero íntegro com o teu
próprio existir e não é verdade se a
gente analisa esses tempos está todo
mundo se sentindo dividindo a cabeça
pensa uma coisa o coração cento e outra
está em briga tá parecendo que o corpo
quer falar uma coisa mas o teu conteúdo
pensamento tal já se impõe diz outras
coisas na frente
não vejo que a gente está dizendo é
muito simples quando criança como foi
dito aqui tu era esse amor essa
expressão essa sinceridade que tá aí
nunca deixou de ser e como adultos um
pouquinho adulterado um pouquinho
condicionado congestionado
a gente começa a carregar um mundo que
de repente não realiza aquela voz
interna
se tem algo que eu trago aqui como uma
possibilidade concreta tangível para
qualquer um que está assistindo agora é
a simplicidade de se voltar para dentro
ouvir a voz de dentro é ouvir a si mesmo
quando você ouvir a si mesmo o
reconhecimento dos talentos dons e natos
e a possibilidade de ofertar isso para o
mundo e poder compartilhar a verdadeira
voz do seu coração
participar dessa sinfonia da vida
tocando a própria música sem se
preocupar com a música do outro pois a
música final é a mesma e bem simples
já dizia sócrates lá atrás o segredo
para a plenitude é compartilhar ea minha
alegria é compartilhar essa trajetória
um pouquinho mesmo que rapidamente com
vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]